28 juin 2016 21h30
nous attendons le chirurgien essam el
haddad dans le stationnement de
l'hôpital de la sarre en abitibi
nous avons tenté de le joindre à
plusieurs reprises son succès docteur el
haddad docteur el haddad
il faudra produire notre reportage sont
les explications du chirurgien un
chirurgien généraliste de la sarre en
abitibi à toucher des revenus d'un
million et demi de dollars l'an dernier
en profitant du système
notre reportage raconte qu'en faisant
plus de 50% de son travail en heures
défavorable
le docteur elhadad réussi à gonfler ses
revenus
depuis plusieurs années le paiement d'un
acte médical effectué le soir la fin de
semaine et les jours fériés et majoré de
70%
la nuit il est majoré 250% le docteur et
la date peut par exemple facturé 1600 $
pour l'ablation d'une vésicule biliaire
lorsque l'intervention se fait la nuit
et 490 $ seulement le jour
ce que fait le docteur el haddad on
appelle ça de la facturation
opportuniste ou facturation créative
avons nous affaire ici à un cas isolé ou
à la pointe d'un iceberg
nous profitons des téléjournaux pour
faire appel aux citoyens
j'aimerais que les gens qui ont vu des
pratiques de facturation qui leur semble
douteuse soit des abus soit quelque
chose
écrivez moi nous nous attendions à
quelques courriels
nous en avons reçu près d'une centaine
la moitié provenaient de médecins ou
d'employés du réseau de la santé qui
dénonçaient des collègues nous avons
décidé d'enquêter sur une vingtaine de
cas et nous avons découvert qu'il est
très facile pour un médecin d'abuser
impunément des fonds publics
au lendemain du reportage sur le docteur
el haddad notre boîte de courriels
déborde la surfacturation c'est une
pratique régulière est connu dans le
réseau et non particulière aux régions
on pointe du doigt une vingtaine
d'hôpitaux parmi lesquels des centres
universitaires à montréal et à québec on
écorche surtout des médecins
spécialistes pour gonfler leurs revenus
les chirurgiens passe de salle en salle
pour observer ou effectuer des pointures
et facturent une honoraires d'assistance
opératoire souvent l'assistance n'est
pas requise chirurgien physiatre
microbiologiste anesthésiologiste
l'anesthésiologie ce travail est dans
deux salles en même temps même si c'est
interdit sauf en cas d'urgence il
modifier les heures pourquoi que ça
paraisse interniste obstétriciens
radiologiste chez nous même si des scans
nécessite une interprétation urgente un
radiologiste datant souvent jusqu'à 19
heures pour les lire
afin de bénéficier d'une majoration de
70% deux types de facturation
opportunistes se distingue la pratique
en or défavorables et la multiplication
d'actes inutiles
nos dénonciateur accepte de nous parler
au téléphone mais tous refusent de venir
devant notre caméra
c'est l'omerta qui réussit deux
technologues vient d'être suspendu sans
solde pour plusieurs mois parce qu'ils
ont parlé à une journaliste
du côté des médecins on évoque la peur
d'être ostracisé ya un climat
d'intimidation dans le réseau si je
témoignais ouvertement certains médecins
et voudrait plus travailler avec moi
comme on travaille en équipe ça
deviendra difficile de faire mon travail
à défaut de pouvoir faire parler les
gens on décide de faire parler les
chiffres
pour les obtenir il faut envoyer des
demandes d'accès à l'information à la
ramq eu la régie de l'assurance maladie
du québec
l'exercice est laborieux ils exigent
d'apprivoiser le manuel de facturation
des omnipraticiens qui comporte 504
pages et celui des spécialistes qui
s'étire sur 874 page
à cela s'ajoute 1902 page d'entente dan
ex et de clauses spéciales
on y passe des semaines fin novembre
vingt-et-une demandes sont envoyés elles
devraient permettre de faire la lumière
sur les pratiques déviantes qui nous ont
été dénoncés la ram qui dispose de 30
jours pour nous répondre
c'est la loi
en attendant nous envoyons à mettre jean
pierre ménard avocat spécialisé en santé
une liste des médecins que les courriels
ont identifié nous voulons savoir si
certains d'entre eux ont déjà fait
l'objet de poursuites
c'est comme ça que nous faisons la
connaissance de madame karrigan d'accès
aux contr le médecin dont parle
anna maria carey gun est un chirurgien
orthopédiste de montréal madame
qu'aragon leur rencontre pour la
première fois en 2013
elle souffre de douleurs chroniques au
dos mais déjà deux chirurgiens lui ont
dit qu'ils ne pouvaient rien faire pour
elle
le nouveau chirurgien lui propose
d'opérer un attrapé to be able to one
approbation
en novembre 2013 madame caron guay ne
passe sous le bistouri
voici un extrait du courriels que nous
avons reçus à propos du chirurgien
orthopédiste client opérer madame
kerrigan il y avait un taux élevé de
complications par chirurgie ce qui lui
permettait de faire beaucoup de
révisions payantes et dans les codes de
fusion de la colonne et fusionner plus
de vertèbres que nécessaire
le chirurgien auraient fusionné 8
vertèbres dans le bas du dos et la
région lombaire en novembre dernier près
de trois ans après l'opération
madame kerrigan a décidé de le
poursuivre la poursuite allègue que la
chirurgie à causer des séquelles
neurologiques une aggravation des
douleurs de madame car gun et une
détérioration de ses capacités et alex
surtout s'appuyant sur l'avis d'un
expert chirurgien orthopédiste que la
chirurgie n'était pas indiqué madame
n'avait pas les cons sont prêtes opéré
n'a sauf madame avait pas de limitations
fonctionnelles suffisant pour justifier
qu'on fasse une opération qui risque
effectivement porter un risque élevé
c'est au terme de la poursuite seulement
que nous saurons si la chirurgie était
indiquée ou pas pour ce qui est des
motifs qui ont incité le chirurgien a
opéré pour le moment lui seul les
connaît
on est en voie de changer comme le
bistouri très facile mais le problème
c'est que la motivation je m'étais
habitué suivante ils établirent parce
que parfois il y en a qui ont
l'éducation opératoire très large puis
en médecine bay on veut parfois accepter
ces pratiques là avant de penser que
c'est motivé par d'autres intérêts
j'ai peu teinté revenir auprès des
médecins qui multiplie les actes et
inutile le collège des médecins
il était bien sûr plein mais le collège
dans ce métal a fait preuve d'une très
grande timidité les contrôles internes
d'octroyer des contrôles et idem mais
tout ça c'est confidentiel
ça se fait derrière des portes fermées
l'âge de 100 ans maladie du québec pour
avoir des pouvoirs plus importants pour
faire ça ne veut pas le faire ne jamais
fait non plus qui au québec s'assure
qu'on ne paie pas pour des actes
médicaux inutiles
autrement dit qui au québec s'assure
qu'on en a pour notre argent
j'ai peur que la réponse à cette
question là soit personnes damien
contandriopoulos et professeur à
l'université de montréal
il dirige actuellement une étude sur
l'impact du mode de rémunération des
médecins sur la performance du système
de santé
selon lui le système québécois à deux
faiblesses à l'acte et on a décidé que
personne n'était capable de regarder 15
ans qui était fait acquis quand pourquoi
si on cumule les deux est une énorme
boîte noire dans laquelle on est certes
inquiet ce parti d'abus on n'a aucune
capacité de savoir ces abus lancer une
fraction infinitésimale qui est
problématique usta gros morceau le
problème et suivant la ram qu a le
mandat de dépister les médecins qui
facturent des actes qui n'ont pas été
posées si un acte a été posée qu'il soit
pertinent ou pas el pais sévir contre
les médecins qui multiplie les actes
inutiles
c'est le mandat du collège des médecins
le problème c'est que le collège n'a pas
accès aux bases de données de la ram cul
qui lui permettrait de débusquer les
abuseurs
ou le mettrais bien c'est que les gens
qui possèdent les banques de données ne
peuvent pas faire les enquêtes complètes
ce n'est pas leur mandat c'est le nôtre
mais nous on n'a pas accès aux banques
de données en général on peut pas dire
donnez moi par exemple le portrait de
tout ce qui se fait comme chirurgie au
québec on n'aurait pas accès à sion
depuis une dizaine d'années à cause des
lois sur les informations personnelles
le pdg de la ram qu est au courant du
problème la demande du collège la cedh
d'avoir l'ensemble des banques de
données pour faire des études puis aller
au-devant de certaines situations mais
il n'y a pas le droit d abord
l'activation par sympa même de changer
la loi
les chercheurs comme damien
contandriopoulos vivent les mêmes
frustrations on a des endroits au québec
dans lesquels on sait qu'on a des taux
d'intervention pour des chirurgies qui
sont beaucoup plus élevés que la moyenne
ça c'est inquiétant ça veut dire soit
les gens sont plus malades soit on les a
peur pour rien c'est les deux hypothèses
dans les deux cas on aimerait le savoir
est ce qu'on peut faire la recherche là
dessus ne peut pas on ne peut pas accès
aux données sur les droits
d'intervention
ça c'est juste des exemples mais au
québec on est de plus en plus dans un
système dans lequel on n'a pas accès aux
données dès que ça touche à la
rémunération des médecins
vous entendrez jamais publiquement un
directeur un cadre un employé du réseau
qui tique est médecin pourquoi ça se
fait pas ça ne se fait pas dans le
réseau chine le chef de chirurgie le
chef de médecine va au conseil
d'administration critique on n'aime pas
le dg vous construire tout le temps le
dg restera pas très longtemps dans
l'établissement avant de devenir
sculpteur à plein-temps dvd le 20 il a
été directeur général de plusieurs
hôpitaux
maître anne-marie chiquette et chef du
contentieux de la per une association
qui représente les cadres du milieu de
la santé
tous les deux nous ont parlé de
l'impuissance des gestionnaires face au
corps médical les médecins ce sont des
travailleurs autonomes ils ont chacun
leur aura dans l'hôpital on les encadre
peau on ne fait pas leur pays dakar on
fait pas de prévisions il n'y a pas de
dévaluation y arriver on n'a pas les
qualités de les gérer
on peut influencer on peut encourager
on peut souligner on peut chercher des
données et montrer les damnés dans
l'espoir d'un changement de comportement
on peut pas dire un médecin par exemple
savez le bloc opératoire yuv à cet art
le mât fin tout le monde et l'eau à 7
heures le matin le patient il ya 7
heures le matin auriez vous l'obligeance
d'être là à 7 ans le mapaï non pas à
8h30 le matin on dit souvent que on fait
trop de demandes de tests laboratoire on
fait trop de demandes de tests
d'imagerie on donne trop de
prescriptions à nos patients
mais ces trois catégories là le dg peut
absolument à veiller faille
de retour dans notre boîte de courriels
j'aimerais vous informer de la pratique
abusive d'un néonatologiste des
nouveau-nés très vulnérable subissent
des soins abusif et nous payons tous
pour cela nous avons recueilli plus d'un
témoignage sur la pratique du médecin
ce médecin connu pour son approche
interventionniste et opportuniste
consultations entre médecins de même
type lean planification d'intervention
évasive en soirée plutôt que sur le
quart de jour ordonnance d'examens
médicaux et de prélèvements dépassant
les protocoles en vigueur pose de
cathéters centraux chez des nouveaux nés
qui n'en n'ont pas besoin
un soir à 23 heures
il a fait enlever un soluté un bébé pour
lui m cathéter centrale alors que le
bébé allait très bien les consulter le
lendemain matin l'autre médecin l'a fait
enlever un cathéter centrale on installe
propres aux 24 heures c'est du temps
c'est de l'équipement coûte cher en
obstétrique les néonatologiste nous
impose clairement de leur demander des
consultations
ce sont des consultations
interdisciplinaire très payante si on
les appelle pas pour faire de la
réanimation
on se fait reprocher quand c'est nous
qui le faisons c'est compris dans notre
tarif pour l'accouchement si je viens de
faire c'est un surplus une consultation
c'est souvent tout à fait justifiée mais
il semble que cela se fasse aussi par
complaisance quand un patient
hospitalisé fait de la fièvre
son médecin demande une consultation en
infectiologie pourtant il devrait être
capable de gérer une fièvre lui même si
le patient des palpitations
il demande une consultation un autre
spécialiste les spécialistes peut passer
tous les jours pour suivre la condition
est facturé une visite chaque fois
qu'ils contrôlent sa personne alors
c'est une pratique généralisée
si on met à fait en consultation de
complaisance il y aurait trop de
médecins spécialistes au québec
nous avons obtenu des statistiques sur
le nombre de consultations par patient
dans les urgences de plusieurs hôpitaux
à l'hôpital de rouyn noranda 4%
seulement des visites auprès des
patients sont des consultations
demandées par le médecin traitant à des
spécialistes à rolle un autre hôpital
régional ses 27%
cette fois plus les différences sont
aussi énormes dans les centres
universitaires 12% à l'hôpital
saint-sacrement à québec 31% à l'hôpital
fleurimont de sherbrooke
comment expliquer de tels écarts ce soit
qu'une partie de la réponse c'est qu'il
ya des milieux dans lesquels ya plus de
complaisance beaucoup de métiers
surfacturé s'en rendent même plus compte
si un résident a même un patient la nuit
et fait une intervention
le lendemain matin le médecin qui
supervise le résident à vos factures et
l'intervention comme s'il l'avait fait
l'humain on peut considérer que c'est de
la daube facturation mais nos
associations nous disent que c'est
correct
damien contandriopoulos est formel les
médecins ne sont ni plus ni moins
honnêtes que le citoyen moyen
le problème c'est leur système de
rémunération
un système est un système qui favorise
filière récompense l'opportunisme fait
là on met des gens ordinaires dans un
système qui récompense la créativité
facturation de l'opportunisme qu'est ce
qu'on a on a pendant ce temps dans les
années 80 il existait environ 600 code
d'actes médicaux
il y en a maintenant 11 mille c'est un
bar ouvert dont il est facile d'abuser
impunément les situations des fois
particulières comme les deux exemples
que vous nous donnez dans des
établissements où c'est difficile pour
un système de rémunération avec les
meilleurs contrôles aux mangues de tout
détecter ces choses là selon plusieurs
personnes à qui nous avons parlé il
faudrait que les données détenues par la
ramq eu soit utiliser davantage pour
comparer les profils des médecins
établir des moyennes et d'identifier des
pratiques moins pertinente
mais ces délits corde parce que la
pertinence de l'acte arrive à être une
jugement ce que le médecin fait mais
c'est nécessaire à mon avis pas c'est
uniquement dans l'évaluation du
pertinence de lacq qu'on va mettre un
contrôle sur les coûts de notre système
de santé
david le vine ne s'en est jamais caché
il pense que les médecins qui pratiquent
dans les hôpitaux devraient être salarié
si on avait eu l'hominisation à salaire
depuis très longtemps au québec
le système de santé québécois sera
complètement complètement différent la
question de pertinence de l'intervention
on était déjà mieux cibler au mieux
organisés qu'est-ce que ça règlerait
d'un réseau de tous les médecins
deviennent des salariés qu'on peut gérer
si on peut les gérer
on peut planifier on peut planifier on
peut économiser on peut on peut discuter
avec eux des meilleures pratiques et des
meilleures manières pour que ça nous
coûte moins cher qu'on en fasse plus
pour le chercheur le salariat n'est pas
nécessairement la solution mais des
changements s'imposent dans le système
de rémunération actuel
pourquoi on sortirait pas ce système là
pour essayer de créer un système qui
favorise les comportements indésirables
puis quand on va sur le terrain ya plein
de milieux de pratique dans lesquels les
médecins s'organisent en groupes se
donne des airs collectif se partagent
les affaires peau nue créative font ce
qu'ils peuvent pour régler les problèmes
d'accès on en voit plein de choses comme
ça au québec mais c'est pas favorisé par
les stèles au québec
le paiement à l'acte est loin d'être
remise en question la tendance est
plutôt à la hausse en 2015 80 2% des
revenus des médecins spécialistes
québécois provenait du paiement à l'acte
alors que dans l'ensemble du canada la
moyenne était de 58% pour contrer les
abus
on mise plutôt sur le renforcement des
contrôles
une nouvelle loi prévoit depuis peu des
amendes très salée pour les abuseurs qui
seront identifiés la loi l'y dissuasive
parce que déjà déjà actuellement que
l'entente démarche envers la ram q7
dénoncé aux autres même à cause des
conséquences de cette loi ne le
savez-vous
la régie de l'assurance-maladie
modernise ses systèmes de rémunération à
l'être le pdg de la ram qu mise aussi
sur le fait que les médecins seront
désormais obligés de transmettre leurs
factures sur support électronique
c'est un outil joue le du lot qui vont
nous permettre d'aller chercher même
déco atypique de facturation des cas
individuels ou même déco de masse
la ramq il affirme qu'elle aura droit
sous peu à de la main d'oeuvre
supplémentaire si l'on en juge par les
réponses qui nous sont parvenues à la
suite de nos demandes d'accès à
l'information
les renforts seront les bienvenus la ram
qu a eu le temps de répondre de façon
très partielle à seulement 5 de nos 21
une demande malgré une prolongation des
délais prévus par la loi
l'une de ces demandes portaient sur le
pourcentage des actes facturés
le soir la nuit et les week end par des
chirurgiens généraux
nous avons obtenu les données pour une
quarantaine d'hôpitaux
douze d'entre eux affichaient des taux
de plus de 35 % d' actes facturés
pendant les plages horaires payante
alors que la moyenne québécoise est de
10%
un des hôpitaux affichait même taux de
82 pour ça pour ce qui est du docteur el
haddad au lendemain de notre reportage
de septembre 2016
une enquête a été déclenchée ces
conclusions viennent d'être rendues
publiques
l'enquète corrobore que le chirurgien a
abusé du système que le directeur
général de son établissement
la laisser faire et que la ras le cul
n'a rien vu la situation à semble-t-il
été corrigés et selon nos informations
les revenus du docteur elhadad aurait
chuté de moitié depuis notre passage à
la sarre